八佩特入股之後比亞迪聲名鵲起
股票從8塊錢一把漲到80
一年的時間漲到80
成為了全世界或者說全香港
資本市場最受關注的那個量載
我們在2009年2010年
的發展也是大跨步的往前走
但是坦白的說
那個時候我們的步子有點大
到了一年王總在公司內部大會上
也開始反思
那個時候我們遇到了種種的挑戰
其實損益表開始出問題
其實盈利上有一些
從而也帶來了
投入有大
資產負債表也遇到挑戰
尤其重要的是上下游的夥伴
客戶受到了傷害
我們的F6等一系列的車型並不成功
我們的經銷商我們的退往實店
王總也在反思我們過去三年
認為是個調整期
我想您作為我們最緊密的
我想您作為我們最堅實的投資者
在當時這幾年的過程
你心裡產生變化了嗎
就這樣啊
我們關注的這個公司
是它的長期內在價值的變化
其實股價的變化對我們影響
確實不是太大
無論是它漲了十倍
還是後來跌了80%
其實我們既沒有一股賣掉
也沒有一股買進來
我們還是原來的基本的市場
但是這三年
公司本身發生了很大的變化
一方面它在很多方面都高歌猛進
另一方面又在高歌猛進中
犯下了一系列
可能這個行業都會犯的錯誤
就你回頭來看
比阿尼在這些年犯的錯誤
其實在過去
這個行業為什麼是著名的墳場
是有道理的
其他的企業
在它的發展不同的過程中
很多犯過類似的錯誤
也有很多失敗
也有很多徹底消失
所以這個行業
首先是充滿了挑戰的行業
但是我們很重要的一點
就是在整個拓展的過程中
其實我們一直想做的事
仍然是拓展我們對於車本身的理解
對它整個零部件的理解
對它規模化生產的把控
考慮的還是電池如果發展到足夠的階段
這場革命還是會發生
但是在這個過程中
我們有好多行業是要養未來的行業
互相的去養
但是在這個養的過程中
這個行業養別的行業就特別的困難
辛苦
而且充滿了挑戰和風險
那麼在這三年裡
我們對這一點體會的尤其深刻
所以這個事給了我們很大的教訓
但是確實也是成長中的煩惱
也是我們必須要經歷的過程
我並沒有覺得這個有什麼特殊的地方
因為這樣的錯誤
幾乎所有的車企都經歷過
那麼經歷不過去
這個坎兒過不去的就進入到墳場
過去的跨過去的
就會成為後來的偉大的公司
對我們的考驗
其實還是能不能跨過這道坎兒
在這一點上
我們又回到原來的一直的信任
就是我相信我們的團隊
我們相信我們很多的先天的優勢
也相信我們學習的能力
我們其實這些年還有一點
大家還是保持了這個平常心
就是也不會把自己太當回事
無論別人怎麼去評價你
至少我不認為我是什麼神奇
我也不認為王總自己是多少神奇
我們該犯的錯誤都要犯
該要的學習都要學習
但是要堅持永遠的錯誤學習
那最好是從別人的錯誤中學習
不要老在自己的錯誤中學習
這個代價比較大
但是犯了錯誤學習
面對現實
然後永不言敗繼續往前走
就是一個企業能夠走下去
根本的要求
我們不是去學習別人
我們是開拓者
後來學習的要容易多了
開拓者是很難很難
要製造一個不存在的市場
所以你一定要具備很多很多不同的能力
但是具備多少這個度很難把握
所以在這些問題上的探索
有的時候這個錯誤是必要的
這些代價是必須要付出的
每一個成功的企業都要經歷
一系列的鳳凰面板
它不可能就一蹴而就了
所以我還是對你充滿了感謝
您對我的人生也是充滿著啟發
我記得11年左右吧
我有點崩不住了
我對種種的失誤我沒有逃避
我沒有放棄
我也在想公司要改變
要找解決辦法
我不知道你還記得我到洛杉磯
當時你還在洛杉磯
對我在洛杉磯
我到您洛杉磯
我到您辦公室
也是深聊了兩三個小時
可能那個時候我也年輕
我的表達相對更直接
我在找救命稻草
去希望能夠讓公司變得更好
那次聊天對我的人生
是充滿著啟發和重要意義的一次聊天
因為我得到了我的滿意的答覆
或者說我得到了希望鼓勵
您不斷地在鼓勵我
您就是用剛才講的第一性原理
你也跟我講你說李前
我見了非常多的中國企業家
來我這裡交流我中國的企業家
我這些最好的企業家們我都熟悉
但是像王總如此有韌勁
對科學探索的無盡的渴望
如此有邊界感的企業家不多
就衝著這一點你相信比亞迪
一定會越來越好
這是當時我們那兩三個小時
你給我的最大的鼓勵
我記憶非常的猶新
後來在資本市場
因為當時您說到了
一個產業去孵另一個產業
尤其拿汽車這個產業去孵其他產業
而且王總是性格上又是非常的堅決
研發投入是不可以放棄的
不管我經營怎麼樣
今天還是這樣
所以那幾年我的壓力也是比較大的
從12年上市A股上市
13年做點心債
14年閃電配售
15年榮151的A股
而這一系列我和您交流的都是比較多的
也再次感謝你給我的鼓勵
我要感謝你
感謝你在這個過程中
為培植資本市場
培植耐心長期的投資者
對一個成長型的企業真的是至關重要
所以你在這麼多年裡面堅持
做這件事情做得很好
而且建立起別人對你的信任
做得非常的好
感謝
我也向你感謝
14年發生了一件有意思的事
有一天中午一點多鐘
股價突然就莫名其妙的
百分之十幾
百分之二十幾
百分之三十幾
我的桌上的電話
我的手機
我就已經開始運作不過來了
當時也很有意思
非常多的投資者堅定的長期投資者
打電話問我
那天跌到50%
一天跌到50%
堅定的投資者長線的他就問我一句話
李前公司有問題沒有
我給他們說公司沒問題
他們就堅定的敢買了
但是其實我心裡面也沒底
因為資本市場股價的表現
不只是公司有沒有問題
其實還有很多外在的環境
比如我第一時間我問王總
王總公司有沒有什麼事情我不知道的
王總跟我說李前沒有
我基本上就敢回答投資者
公司沒有問題
緊跟著
謠言四起
巴菲特要減持了
李祿要減持了
我當時坦白說我不知道你在哪
但是我不管
我不管是晚上幾點了
我就給你打了個電話
您也很巧
您當時應該在國內
在飛機上
你跟我說李前我在飛機上
我說太好了你接回電話了
我說李祿總現在股價
現在股價你看看股價
股價怎麼了
我說股價已經跌了
百分之十四五十了
我說江湖在傳李祿總您在減持
當時您給了我一個堅定的回答
你說李前
一定不是我
第二我對公司充滿信心
然後有了這個回答
我就敢於向資本市場去傳遞
第一公司沒問題
第二李祿總沒有減持
希巴拉也沒有減持
我們是當天晚上
巴菲特這邊早晨我們聯繫上
知道了他沒有動作
所以在第二天早晨的7點鐘
王總和我召開了一個記者發布會
我們給市場澄清了
當天的股價就漲回30%
後來又回到了原來的位置
而且我也再次表示感謝
而且您又買了300多萬股
因為您看到的是比亞迪的價值
您又繼續支持了比亞迪
我和王總當時也非常的感慨
其實那個時候公司的經營情況
並不是說在已經出現拐點了
當時您也是為了堅定您的信念
是堅定對比亞迪的信念
2020年我們後繼爆發
當年發生兩件事
第一個疫情比亞迪發揮了我們的
中國製造最典型的搞笑軍團作戰
我們的口罩
然後6月份推出來的漢一炮大紅
在這個過程中
在您跟王總有些什麼樣的交流
因為你也是王總的志勇
也是支持者和建議者
在那個關鍵的節點
你和王總的交流的狀態是什麼
19年底2020年初
也是一個特發的事情
我們最早口罩的起因
因為我們剛剛發生武漢的疫情之後
那個時候也是因為
我們看到這種需求非常的交集
所以我在美國發起了一個天使基金會
就是要在美國去動員
能夠動員各種各樣的人力物力財力去支援武漢
那麼當時我遇到的最大的挑戰
就是我們買口罩買不著
買口罩變得很困難一件事情
我到處去找
然後運力一開始發生各種各樣的困難
一個一個的解決
但是解決了以後
其實我們錢也籌到
我自己也投入了很多錢
但是我們買不到
就買的很少
我們能買到的全部買來了
所以當時我跟王總正好在假期的時候在一起
這個時候我跟他談了我們在做的這個事
他就問我最困難的什麼地方
毒點結點
我跟他說口罩
這是我的最大的毒點
他說我來想一想辦法
他這個當天晚上立刻讓這個回去
動員所有的事業部
我們開會
我們開會了分工
這個事可以解決
當時事實話我也很驚訝
但是確確實實在那個之後
慢慢的他就真的做起來了
這個時候又是芒格先生的幫助
我們就跟Costco建立起背書
也是用信譽來去背書
有這樣的製造能力
這是一家了不起的公司
然後關鍵的是我們的美國的認證
還是做得比較完整
在中國已經開始使用
而且非常非常高的
所以我們第一筆大的訂單
就是在Costco6000萬口罩
所以這一下子
就讓我們很多其他地方
因為有這個Costco
我們最早有芒格先生背書
有Costco的第一個訂單
然後之後其他的
有各個地方的需求
全球都來了
一下子的求
我們最後賣了在全球賣了幾十億口罩
所以這個過程
又是一個非常有趣的過程
又再次見證了
第一比亞迪的製造能力
真的是無邊界的製造能力
原創型的思維
第一性原理的思維
工程師的落地
還有受託人的精神
完全不被困難
堅定的毅力
在這刻就爆發出來
在幾個月的時間
我們從一紙手套都沒有
變成了全世界最大的口罩製造商
一天一紙
也是個神奇的過程
這個時候
比亞迪和Berkshire合作
中國和美國互相的信任和背書
又在這一次發揮了巨大的力量
能夠在這一點很短的時間裡
基本上從消費者到各個州
到美國聯邦政府
到歐洲的國家
所有的全球
都在很短的時間
接受了比亞迪的產品
它的質量 它的信誼
也確確實實幫助了無數的人
也是驗證了你剛才說的
你不斷地去幫助別人
確實有好報
好報 人有好報
達人註己
真的是這樣
活靈活現
在短短六個月裡
體現的淋漓盡生
真的是這樣
在比亞迪做口罩之前
全中國的整個口罩產能
一天是兩千萬支
我們比亞迪三天出圖紙
七天收散生產線
從五百萬支一天開始
我們很快到了
一個多月就到了一億支
是全中國所有口罩產能的五倍
而且為中國和全球的紐帶關係
也做出了巨大的貢獻
也為中國的這次防禦
做出了巨大的貢獻
也彰顯了中國製造的能力和優勢
也建立了品牌在海外
幫了人嘛
對 那個時候全球的
中國之外的生產能力
也是只有兩千萬
加在一起全球的生產力就是四千萬
比亞迪一家
最後在六個月裡
看到了一億支
今天的比亞迪
已經是一個中國的世界冠軍
但是呢
比亞迪是一個充滿著夢想的公司
我們正在從中國的世界冠軍
要蛻變成全球的領袖
您覺得比亞迪還有什麼樣的路要走
還會遇到哪些困難和挑戰
技術上 公司治理上
企業文化上 全球責任上
等等我相信
也不會那麼一蹴而就
所以我特別想聽聽您這位智者
從您對人類的文明史
對科技發展的進步和迭代
對價值的發現
給比亞迪再提提一些什麼想法和建議
智者談不上
我們一個真正偉大的企業
實際上是沒有邊界
它的發展也不會停止下來
增長也沒有天花板
我們其實
雖然走了一條很長的路
但是還有更長的路要走
中國在這個節點上發展
也開始進入到一個新的台階
各方面的元素都使得我們下面的
幾十年的發展其實更值得期待
首先就是這個
我們叫全球公司這個概念
Multinational Corporation
最早工業化的歐洲的國家
後來二戰之後的每個國家
實現了真正雖然基於一個國家
但是商業在全球同時發展
那麼現在這個節點上
中國公司開始具備了這樣的機會
這樣的能量這樣的能力
中國提供給這些公司最重要的條件
它是一個巨大的
單一的
大的市場
它又單一
又統一
從regulation上
然後又巨大
同時是市場
是一個開放型的
對全球開放型的市場
這些四個條件合在一起
就使得在這個市場裡面的冠軍
有機會在全球都成為冠軍
而且它一定在當地化
成為當地經濟發展的一部分
不僅僅是出口
所以這個時代是會出現
以中國為基礎全球公司
中國級的全球公司
比亞迪是這個浪潮裡面
重要的一朵浪花
不是唯一的
當然
這個過程才剛剛開始
還有很長很長的路
要走可走
這是一個方面
另一個方面
中國經過四五十年的發展
我們也開始具備了
人才技術市場
各個方面都到了一個
創造力爆發的這樣一個時代
就在這個時代裡頭
原創的技術
原創的產品
了不起的定義行業的企業
都會密集型的出現
在幾乎所有的領域
所以在這個時代
對於一個沒有邊界的企業
能夠用低性原理來思考
公司未來的前進的企業
能夠有工程師的文化
我們又有勞動力的紅利
又有工程師的紅利
又有技術的積累
所以它能夠去
迸發出的創造力會更慘
所以在這個時候
比亞迪是非常幸運的
在這個時代
它就具備了生育
具備了技術的儲備
人才的儲備
規模的優勢
產品的領先
品牌的名譽度
所有這些都在一起
再加上我們的
創學還有公司的員工
仍然處在旺盛的
年齡段和經歷
還在旺盛的時期
我認識王祖二十幾年
他這個生活沒有發生過什麼變化
依舊
仍然是從早一直到半夜
然後第二天重新開始
我們一起要在外面去旅行
尤其是團隊去
一天最重要的會永遠是晚上11點
就是白天所有的工作做完了
11點就開始總結了
然後睡覺之後
第二天早上又開始
精力滿滿
動力滿滿
我們的邊界還很遙遠
增長還非常值得期待
而在這個時候
又是質量和技術爆發的時代
但是我們雖然在技術上常常領先
但是在精細化管理方面
其實又是處在一個非常初級的階段
要管理十幾萬的工程師
幾十萬甚至上百萬的員工
一個很長的產品線
在多個國家
我們還要有好多好多的探索
才能夠真正做到精細化的管理
才能真正做到以客戶為中心
把產品真正的做精做細
還有上十萬個專利
而且不斷地在研發出新的方向
所以這一些潛力要實現
它一直是不斷地在擴大齊全的過程中
它的內在價值一直在增長
所以這個是我們最看重的
我們作為投資人
你看我們擁有23年的時間
其中股價跌了50%以上
大概至少有七八次
一次跌了80%以上
每次漲的也快
但是漲的時候也可以很快
一年一十倍的情況也出現過
所以在這個過程中
如果你是一個投機的心態
是很難真正享受到整個過程的
所以本分一點思考問題
無論是作為管理者還是作為投資人
就掙自己應該掙的這個錢
你應該掙的錢實際上就是
公司本身內在價值不斷地被實現
不斷地增長
最後慢慢被認可時候的那一份
當然我們覺得也非常的幸運
這樣的企業其實很少很少
如果大家企業都是永遠是增長
這個世界我們就真的是
這書長了天上
這個也不太可能
所以這樣的企業是鳳毛麟角
我們的幸運是在很早的時候
發現了這樣一個了不起的企業
這樣一個了不起的企業家
跟隨著企業一起成長一起學習
在這個中間有所幫助
讓我們更加心安理得
您謙虛了
這是您的眼光和智慧挖掘
投資它是你認知的結果
就是您相信你才會投比亞迪
也感謝您對比亞迪包容
就像您寫的這本書
就是您寫的這個叫做
《文明現代化價值投資與中國》
也是我非常喜歡的一本書
因為這本書裡面
你對人類文明的整個進化
以及現代科學的一個迭代
包括價值投資的哲學
你是做了一個系統性的描述
也是給我的人生
對我的人生包括投資
都有很多很多的啟發
雖然現在的世界好像有點亂
現在有句網絡名詞叫
世界就是個草苔班子
但是您又是樂觀的
您對世界的統一大市場
你是長期認為
這是人類發展的必然結果
你也認為文明3.0
應該講要持續為社會和世界
創造出它所需要的價值
這才是根本
我想您剛才對於我提的問題的回答
應該用這個也能完美的闡述
只要比亞地繼續努力
持續為世界和人類
創造更好的更高的價值
那就是我們的使命
我們就能夠去為世界文明做貢獻
而不要去管這個世界
是怎麼個草苔班子
我們做好我們自己吧
說了那麼多
王總不變的有非常多的特點
今天的比亞地
又站在歷史的一個新的舞臺
假如說從過去的20幾年
你和王總的交流友誼
不變的有非常多
但是我又想請問一下
那王總變的又是哪一些呢
一定變了很多
對 我覺得王總身上
我覺得最讓我很欽佩的特質
就是他這個學習的能力
持續學習的能力
所以學習本身
也是一個學習了學習的方法之後
他的學習就開始以輔力的形式
不斷地在前進
真心地體會到
在過去的20幾年
王總對商業的理解
對不同技術的理解
對於實現長期目標短期的量化
對於管理這個龐大
越來越增加的員工和資產
還有市場面臨著各種各樣
複雜的問題
都有了驚人的變化
因為這個就是輔力的力量
但是不僅僅是王總
我們這個公司的高管的團隊
大家還在中司裡面
我們還在堅守還在努力
還有我們下一代更年輕的
這個組織本身
慢慢地就幻化成一個學習的組織
應該說還沒有完全的完成這個過程
我們還要學習的還有很多很多
因為我們增長的這個速度
尤其是在快速增長的時候
它一定會產生很多很多新的問題
我們過去這五年的經驗
其實也不可能永遠的複製
這個是不是這個盤整
這些都是必然的
所以如果說我們對未來
有一個比較現實的期待的話
我們要該犯的錯誤
新的錯誤
我們需要的盤整
這都是必然的
也沒什麼大不了
這個過去的這些經驗
讓我們更加有信心
遇到不同的問題
不同的挑戰的時候
就真正的一步一步地去應對它
每個你走很長很長的路
其實都是左腳在前
右腳在前
左腳在前
一步一步都是這樣走
關鍵是不停地走
不停地走就能夠走得很遠
同時堅定地相信走的方向
我的想法就是
基於理性和常識的樂觀
仍然是人類最好的選擇
但是要基於理性
基於常識
在這個基礎上
堅定的樂觀主義
是讓我們能夠不斷走下去的路
我們過去的印記
幫我們更加有信心
我們的不斷地學習
讓我們具備更多的理性
更多的常識
更明確的方向
但是堅定的腳印
仍然是通向成功唯一的辦法
所以我希望還能夠看到
跟比亞迪一起再走一長遠的道路
作為一路相伴的志友夥伴
我想您給比亞迪下一個三十年
最真摯的祝福或者期待
我已經講過了
我沒有什麼特別的
我也不是一個特殊人
我也沒有什麼題字的本質
每天一步一個腳印就可以
不需要去想的那麼遠
每天踏踏實實的向前走
芒哥先生一個話我很喜歡
每天早上醒來的時候
比昨天的都更聰明一點
學習更多一點就可以了
每天如此
福利的力量是強大無比的
外面的盤整
但是內在的進步
是我們自己都能夠感受到的
我們只要每天都能夠比前一天
稍稍的學習多一點
我們就可以走很遠很遠的道路
所以這種態度
是一個企業能夠去長久走下去
根本文化不僅是個人
要把整個企業
打造成這樣一個學習的機器
能夠不斷以福利的方式去前進
我們就能走很久
這是送給比亞迪的
也是送給我的
我感謝能夠今天這一個多小時的交流
也感謝一直以來你給我的
精神上的一些鼓勵和支持
我希望以後多有機會能向您請教
也希望您一直陪伴著比亞迪
然後我們一起變得每天
你每天變得好一點聰明一點
是的
非常感謝我作為股東
真的是對於所有的比亞迪員工
無論是今天的還是過去的
還是未來的
心存感激之心
非常非常的感謝
再次謝謝李路總
謝謝